hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw I just went
and saw the disaster artist I've been
super excited to see this film as I
think everyone has since the very first
trailer came out
I love the roof I hadn't even heard of
the room until I started working with
nostalgia critic and then Malcolm lent
me his DVD of the room I watched it I've
seen it like four or five times now in
the last three years that I've been
working with NC and gosh it's been more
than that now I think Wow time flags
it's just that wonderful type of bad to
where if it were any sort of good if it
had any merit and any like worth at all
for being a good film it would be
extremely problematic my cats are
scrambling around there's a lot of
villainizing of women there's just
there's a lot there's a lot of problems
in the film obviously we all know this
but because it's so bad it's just such a
delight it's very very much like troll 2
which I recently saw for Tamra's never
seen it's just that like delightful kind
of bad but yeah any time it's on I will
watch that film any time it's on and now
this oh my gosh it's a delight it is
delightful I went and saw it at the
Music Box Theatre in Chicago which is
known for doing midnight screenings of
the room and just live screenings of the
room live but like people throw spoons
and like you know it's one of those just
like giant to do the reactions that the
audience gave added so much and I think
across the board that'll be the case
when you see this film I was worried
that it might be sad to watch it it
might really really villainize Tommy was
though to a point where it's like oh God
just uncomfortable that he knows that
this is like a thing but like he was in
the film and it really came off as like
yeah this guy is kind of a dick kind of
a jerk but also it's like this is his
passion project and this is just you
know this is the story of how it how it
all happened it did it in a human way
versus like I don't know it wasn't as
dramatic and sad as I thought it was
going to be which is good I read the
first 1/3 of the disaster artist I was
talking with someone recently and they
said that it's it might even be better
if you read the book after because the
book is just jam-packed with so much and
it's so funny is so good just why it
inspired the movie in the first place
but maybe hold off on that till after so
you're not like disappointed it's like
the book is always better kind of thing
and and I think I'm I'm glad that I did
because I think though the movie is so
so so good I do think that it's getting
a bit over height we went in to see it
and somebody came up in front of the
theater and like he was a critic in
Chicago and he was he was talking about
the film a little bit before we watched
it and he was like I don't like to over
hide things but this is the funniest
film I've ever seen and like that fans
oh that's a pretty big overtime if you
ask me and so you you go in with an
expectation and it was a very very very
funny but it definitely wasn't the
funniest movie I've ever seen and there
were a few moments so were that could
have been cut I think especially in the
first 2/3 the last the last end of the
film was so good God the very end
amazing and then like you wait for the
credits and then the very very end
amazing but there was a there's a few
things that could have been cut in in
the beginning the cast was out of this
world they were so good so many people
from Parks and Recreation which is my
favorite show of all time
so that delighted me to my core
zac efron was so random I didn't look at
the cast list before seeing the film so
people would pop in and I'd be like wait
what it's it's the guy from Hunger Games
what are you doing here Josh hutchinson
but James Franco let's talk about James
Franco
everyone hates James Franco for some
reason he was like beloved for a while
and then people started hating him I
don't really know why so if there's a
reason let me know I thought this is
probably his best work that he's ever
done I think he did such a good job so
at the end you sees him side by side of
like the actual film and then recreating
certain scenes and he does a killer job
with being Tommy razón it's it's crazy
good he's he's genuinely so so wonderful
in this film and so is his brother I
don't know much about dave Franco but he
was a great Greg Sestero
he looked a lot like him and it was a
perfect match the casting in this was
incredible seth rogen dan he was like
subtle but still seth rogen but like
subtle enough to where it wasn't like I
don't know I think he's a funny guy but
sometimes he's a little like he'll take
over the whole space and take over the
whole scene and I don't think that he
did that in this I think he really
pulled it back and it was perfect for
for the part I really enjoyed though how
James Franco turned it into more of an
affectionate kind of like playful haha
making fun of kind of thing versus I
don't know bringing it didn't feel cool
at all I just really want to know what
Tommy thinks of the film the guy who was
speaking before the film played was
saying that he was there at the oh hi
Wendy good kitty baby he was there at
the
very first screaming of the disaster
artist back in June I think he said and
he was like I think Tommy was just like
stunned speechless he didn't say much
after I don't know how I would feel
after seeing a film made about me making
my passion project that got a much
different reaction that I thought it was
I just don't know how I would feel about
seeing this film or about me it seems
like they they've changed a couple
things from the parts that I read of the
disaster artist but not much it felt
like it was just for the screenplay it
made sense I I think that it was it was
pretty like accurate um and maybe even
like a little nice on the nice side of
things it just felt like they they knew
though the cult behind this film they
knew the love towards it and they wanted
to make this love story for the room and
they did and it was it was really
wonderful i I kind of went in feeling
like it was gonna be this non-stop laugh
fest it wasn't there were some stressful
scenes because Tommy is an uncomfortable
man from what I can gather at some of
the situations that he got him and Greg
into were just very uncomfortable and oh
my god the scene where he is filming the
sex scene for the room was so
uncomfortable and I was so horrified for
that actress
oh hi Ike oh hi Ike oh hi Ike good kitty
I know this will never happen and it it
shouldn't win best picture of the year
but how funny would it be if the room
the worst film of all time won best film
this year like if the disaster artist
won best film that would be amazingly
just what a great story I would love
that
it won't happen and it shouldn't happen
it wasn't the best film of the year but
it is very good and seeing it with an
audience I think was doubled the
enjoyment it was so much fun to see the
iconic moments in the room
being made on screen in front of you and
then seeing and hearing and feeling the
audience's reaction was just super super
worth it it's so cool that this terrible
film that this awful script of this this
man who in all rights should never have
been an actor his passion projects has
created this giant phenomenon of like
all of these screenings and like the
spoon throwing and yelling things on the
screen and like and and now there's a
full film can you imagine if you made a
film and then like years later James
Franco was like I'm gonna play you in
the film about making your film
definitely go see it definitely go see
it in the theatre if you can it is it's
so fun it is so so so much fun I think
probably James Franco's best performance
ever
as Tommy often says before screaming's
you can laugh you can cry just don't
hurt anybody thank you so much for
watching everyone I will see you all
next week
ah you're tearing me apart I do that
wrong you're tearing me apart i funny
story
[Music]